Last of Us episode I wish I didn't play
the video game
uh
uh yeah I love the video game but you're
gonna love season two and three yeah
yeah okay by the way I was right about
uh season two and three remember let's
split it up I said they gotta split it
up oh yeah but uh
but what's it called yeah so The Last of
Us episode if you play the video game
that that episode sucked
um yeah I didn't play the video game so
the episode again was a little bit like
nah but then at the end I was like what
the [__] That's How It Ends yeah like if
I didn't know there's a season two or
three
that would have been a [__] craziest
ending yeah um yeah I I think that that
makes sense
100 that's why I wish I didn't do and I
feel like there are a bunch of other
episodes in the season that were awesome
to so many people but because I knew
what happened yeah like for example
yeah yeah so this is going to be your
experience 100 all the other Seasons my
issue with this episode is it should
have been two
this should have been two episodes how
it should have been happy go lucky
everything's good we get to the new
place we're seeing the science we're
seeing what everybody's working on they
rekindle their relationship with the
fireflies Ellie rekindles her
relationship with Melinda and they
haven't seen each other in so long and
they're loving each other they're eating
everything's happy everything's [__]
good and then last scene is Melinda
going okay we're gonna have to kill
we're talking to the doctor he goes yeah
we're the only way we can do is we have
to kill her and the second episode would
have just been him shooting the place up
exactly that's not a whole episode
that's the episode
an hour to two hour episode hour and 20
minutes
yeah I didn't like the whole slow effect
of him killing everybody like nah
stretch that [__] out I wanted to see
that [__] did did you just say
I said stretch it out but not a whole
episode and stop laughing because you
ain't see it
but I saw this and this is awesome
no he went to school with some kids who
played the video yeah we had a kid that
actually he was a clicker growing up
yeah he was so I I thought um yeah I
thought it was really weird when I was
watching him go through the the hospital
I was like
you're kind of an [__] killing all
these [__] like which I think
they want you to feel he snaps he snaps
because he's like I'm gonna do anything
to protect my daughter yeah and I think
there are a lot of people with kids they
were like that if you have kids you
understand what he's doing yeah it's
incredibly relatable I'll do anything to
protect my daughter
I don't have kids so I'm like I think he
could have negotiated a bit
either she dies or the world dies like
here's where I kind of understood
I don't this doctor is for sure right
this is a theory you're gonna kill my
daughter over here like no yeah when the
world is at that point yeah
I don't know yeah it's your daughter I
know you be killing daughters no problem
I was about 12 years too late
so they I don't know if you guys don't
know uh you haven't played the video
game part two but there's another
character in part two which is uh her
name is Abby why are you running for all
of us too no this is plot and Abby's
kids this [__] shut up I hate
them
sitting there knowing every week we're
gonna watch this talk about this show
and it's going to be our best performing
clip and he just sits there like an
[__] and pretends like he knows
you're gonna ruin it yeah a couple
references that like kind of sound like
he knows what's going on yeah well the
clickers oh yeah I know that was the
first four episodes and beat the game
basically all right guys we need to take
a break from this exclusive patreon clip
because I gotta make sure them boners
are stiff you heard me I'm telling you
Bluetooth is the way to go okay same
active ingredients is Viagra sea house
but this is the cutest one that we rock
with this is one that your wife deserves
this one's your girl deserve this one
your side chick deserves okay this one
you do deserve whatever it is they
deserve it and you deserve it too and if
you use the code flagrant
you can get your first month free go to
bluetooth.com all you gotta do is pay
five dollars shipping bluetooth.com
promo code flagrant now let's get back
to this exclusive patreon clip join the
[__] Army watch the whole episode at
patreon.com flagrant Peace So this girl
Abby who's part of the part two
and this is when you know [__]
are like getting into the show there's
this scene Abby has like a big braid
there's a scene when Joel is going
through the hospital where a girl kind
of runs down the hallway and for a
second you see the braids
hold it to frame and then keep running
you would barely pick it up but dudes
are so obsessed with the show that they
look for it and that'd be really cool
that'd be really cool foreshadowing
because there is in the game you see
this moment from her perspective and you
get to play it as her perspective so if
they have that scene and they just get
to match it yeah that's fine I'm sure
that'll be an intro in the same way that
uh Ellie's mom giving birth to Ellie was
an intro that you saw there will be a
flashback yeah where she relives the
scene yeah yeah and that's gonna be fire
but I agree with you I thought it was
mid I didn't I wasn't
I was into it what was the the reaction
from people who hadn't played the game
though so again I thought it was like
kind of crazy you're watching this guy
it's uncomfortable because you see him
snap like clearly this guy is [__]
lost it now he's killing everyone
blindly yeah and again you understand
why but it's like this is kind of crazy
watching Joel act like this yeah he's
like back to the guy he was before that
you heard about that you didn't really
see yeah and it's weird that like love
brought him back there yeah like love
was the thing that brought him out yeah
now love brings him back to that like
really [__] up dark place and then the
ending [__] with you when she asked him
and she knows he's lying yeah and he
tells the whole story and even the way
he's telling the story I mean Peter
Pascal is amazing isn't it the way he's
telling the story it's like a guy
snapped and he's almost like creating an
alternate reality for both of them yeah
like he's trying to believe in himself
and it was just [__] it really was
like God damn I did not think it was
gonna end like this I also didn't know
they're gonna have to kill her but I
didn't think that was gonna happen yeah
yeah I feel like she knew that they were
gonna have to kill her
and she didn't want to tell him that
yeah Melinda [__] is a dumb as [__]
yeah why are you telling him just hey
it's just a quick surgery a little
procedure
Oh you mean okay just shoot this
[__] you know what he's like
yeah Loki she died in surgery oops Yeah
we lost her yeah yeah and then he still
snaps but you just kill him you don't
even snap it's like he goes I understand
that sucks but she would have wanted it
this way but the fact that you're not
even you're telling him you're gonna
murk her and you said there's a remember
before she goes you're the one guy I
didn't want to be indebted to yeah
because she knows he's [__] crazy and
can kill everybody she literally goes
how did you guys make it here all of my
men died getting from Boston to here you
guys made it here it's like [__] kill
him yeah
what are you doing you're gonna send
these two douchebags to leave them on
the road with him walk him out to the
highway what the [__] is wrong with you
yo yeah this really made me not want a
female president this show anytime women
are in power they just [__] the whole
thing up
you brought it up in Kansas that one
woman that was in power oh yeah she was
a [__] psychopath
you're out yo both of y'all are out yeah
man yeah it's a it was a it's a but I
think about ending a video game like
that oh bro it's crazy you go over kill
everybody like that's your objective and
the video game ends like that's the
ending the world is still in hell I
don't save the world I saved my daughter
that's fine it's not even my daughter my
adopted daughter that I met about six
months ago
that's fine that last round of the game
or whatever they call it that must have
been like crazy getting out of the
[__] hotel oh dude
whenever they play it out and you're
like what a little bit but also you're
so unexpected so you're just stoked
you're like oh that's great that you did
that to me yeah you did make this like
some Hollywood ending yeah yeah I mean
two is [__] awesome too because you
play from both sides
yeah it's like Abby's father is the
doctor uh uh I don't I didn't give away
too much so Abby's father is the doctor
that's killed that's why Abby wants to
come back and get Joel and pay Joel back
uh right so that's how they kind of
engage they're like search party out for
this [__] so you play as Abby
and you play as what you said so she's
you said people are saying she was in
the scene was she one of the nurses that
he didn't kill no oh she's it's like you
barely see her and I think they did that
on purpose because maybe they haven't
chosen the actress for her yet so they
should just kind of in the shadow but
you do see like a little parade go by
because I thought it was one of the
nurses
wow I see you kill my dad right in front
of me like Vendetta do you get why
people didn't like the second game
so I think they didn't like the second
game because it was a
like Trifecta of
they basically like you could argue
forced in the trifecta of like uh
extreme right-wing uh talking points
where
there's like a trans kid in it they're
lesbians like uh Ellie's a lesbian right
and uh out of nowhere they're like in a
synagogue so it's like trans the Jews
and gay gay thing just like kind of gets
forced into this thing there's also
another event that happens but I don't
want to ruin it for anybody it's
actually really funny the synagogue
scene is hilarious because like
they're in the synagogue
and then the Jewish girl yeah starts
explaining to Ellie like what the Jews
have gone through yeah yeah and it's
like
everybody's dead yeah hmm I only lost
six million we lost six billion we look
everybody like everybody's dead but
she's like you don't know it's like the
Inquisition like
like my people have really gone through
it and it's like everybody's a mushroom
now yeah yeah like there's another thing
happening yeah that's that's kind of a
tone deaf Scene It was so tough but I
think the guy who created Israeli yeah
so I'm sure he's maybe even influenced
by it yeah in a way right but uh I was
just so funny playing the game so I
could see how like these extreme
right-wing people who are thinking it
like a gay agenda and a trans agenda and
a Jewish agenda is taking over Hollywood
now it's taking over video games right
and it was inserted but the story is so
dope anyway you're just [__] locked
in yeah you're playing the lead
character in a movie or in the second
one's even longer so it's like imagine
like being Tony Soprano in This Promise
um like it's [__] sick some people
don't like that type of video gaming I
guess like they prefer like the GTA
style which is like open worlds yeah
yeah
but I don't know I kind of like I I like
playing the lead character in a [__]
story that's predetermined a little
cutscene you can chill you got very
specific missions do this yeah yeah it's
kind of nice that someone is telling you
what to do yeah yeah so much I don't
know I think I like I think if I like
Lego for that reason just because I have
the instructions so much of your life is
just like all right you gotta figure
this out you have all this [__] to do no
one's telling you what you just got to
do it and figure it out yeah but then
when you have this thing it's like okay
it's just gonna tell me what to do yeah
this game is like do this and if you
don't do it you can try until you get it
you're like nice it makes things very
easy yeah in a world where like I think
people with uh if you got a desk job and
you got like seven bosses above you and
you're like working at like on a Google
you're like yo I want to play open world
where I can do anything anything I want
you know I had so much rigidity in my
life I want some Freedom yeah I want to
go rob that car I want to go [__] that
prostitute yeah
yes yes yes yes yes yes it's like uh
they say that often like your your
sexual expression is like the opposite
of what your your life and job is so
like uh cops want to be dominated
because they have so much control and
this is not every single person but you
often kind of see them like the BDSM is
for people who have so much control and
are very controlling in their everyday
life and their job so they want to be
dominated with Wall Street Leo's getting
[__] the candle in his ass and all
that yeah yeah so but yeah that's
interesting so wait so what do you
prefer do you like the open games or the
uh I like FIFA so that's the thing like
FIFA I like this competitiveness yeah
that's it it's just like another way I
can compete with my friends and talk
[__] simple as that yeah like I I didn't
even like soccer I like FIFA yeah
exactly yeah like all of us Americans in
college we're playing FIFA we hadn't we
never watched a single soccer game yeah
it's weird UCSB my school won the NCAA
Championship we played FIFA every day
didn't go
[Laughter]
I'm too fast you got Scott Sterling
Vibes I mean I do look like every goalie
yeah yeah wait you said you're too fast
that's why you can't be goalie yeah too
fast take you want me on the pitch oh
yeah he's running up and down the pitch
yeah
soccer haircut right now what the hell
haircut is for you guys I like haircut
all right this is oh yeah isn't that
nice that none of us Rose you yeah
I thought you didn't because we talked
about it on brilliant idiots yeah I like
it really he just slow rolled the
episode that's the way he did yeah yeah
he said he like it oh
they hating Brothers damn right but you
notice that he liked everyone's outfits
today you notice that
um you notice that he liked everyone's
outfits
one episode
I was wearing the exact sweater the
other day just purple and he's like yeah
you look crazy you you should got
foreskin but you are fire this outfit is
simple but the sneaker pulls it in with
the watch I love it
Simplicity great I love that and Mark
your outfit's nice I like your outfit
thank you
it's so great oh great so great cook him
I don't got nothing
this is not I like this minimalism on
you this is great
this is great so that feels
condescending
this is this is class this is done right
this is good this is great covered baggy
it's great you're perfect one of the
better outfits I've seen you wear
you've worn basically the same outfit
this is that one jacket that he's got
it's like it's a very you're basically
just complimenting you yeah as long as
you dress like me
bro I'm just saying the more you dress
like me
this is very this is a great fit for you
you look excited I do remember I had
that jacket on just like with a red
collar the other day so yeah so this one
right here yeah very similar
yeah man just tan with the red collar so
it must have been a great outfit no I
know yeah so you you know we're just
dressing like each other yeah yeah
complimenting each other yeah
yeah that's what that's what we are
doing all right
we look [__] fantastic don't you
think yeah haircut awesome
the haircut is atrocious it's not my
choice this is for the role and it's so
bad it's not even funny and I have to go
up in front of people and perform
do you acknowledge it yes immediately is
it nice you have a thing though dude
it's actually kind of funny how easy it
is having a thing don't you look like
the bad military guy from Avatar
in Avatar
it's a [__] that gets remade
that's funny Nah when I say uh I said I
was like I was like I don't know what it
is about this haircut but all of a
sudden I got strong opinions about the
Jews
I was like six million
how did we know it's six yeah no it's a
great haircut dude no it's brutal
nothing to say about it it's Bruce how
was acting uh you know this time is
actually fun no that's not close come on
no come on not even the races it's not
even in the right ballpark that's the
same thing no you got to get Brad Pitt
all Google in front of you that's the
best you can do son every haircut that's
the one all right fine what don't pull a
Brad Pitt if you're gonna be like dude
Brad Pitt yeah if you're trying to make
fun of me you got to make fun of me a
Brad Pitt it looks like Brad Pitt
Brad Pitt look-alike so basically what
it is